[Applaudissements]
alors je dis donc on va essayer de le
faire donc pour pouvoir faire 30 pas mon
poste je vais juste demandé aux
personnes d'origine mexicaine de quitter
le plateau s'il vous plaît merci merci
aux mexicains pour pouvoir faire preuve
à mon pote les chéris avant de démarrer
les missions j'aurais demandé à toutes
les femmes de sortir ça passera pas
merci merci merci a bientot mer var
merci bonjour l'ambiance alors va rester
entre eux ça va être pareil enfin 30 pas
mon poste awards et bien on va en fait
bien là on est bien là non merci merci
les cherry pour pouvoir faire un truc
pas mon poste les chéris je vais
demander aux personnes gays de sortir un
très bon hockey de sortir son gérant des
vues
[Rires]
via le site novak d'avoir une part pas
tout seul merci dans la main enfin les
cherry pour pouvoir faire se trompent
pas mon poste je vais demander à tous
les étrangers de sortir du plateau de
beille
salut les gars ça lui est cher
jeudi était au dessus
le broker